tens of thousands of Afghan migrants are
on the move on the Pakistani side of the
Border While others wait in a long queue
for their final
paperwork after crossing the border into
Afghanistan they wait for their turn in
the open air to get a shelter many had
homes and livelihoods in Pakistan but
are now living in a makeshift camp for
now rafik Kula and his children live in
a tent and worry about what comes next
we did not believe the news but then the
authorities came and told us to leave or
face arrest we left in a hurry I had to
leave my livestock money owed to me by
locals and even a m Bak now I have
nothing and don't know what I will
do the vehicles keep arriving and these
families wait for their turn to get a
tent jumadin tells us about his
oral we had no time to pack our
belongings including the a pot of rice
on the
stove the camp keeps growing and more
and more people arrive after suddenly
ordering the expulsion of 1.7 million
unregistered afans the interim
government in Islamabad is now telling
the 1.5 million registered and
documented Afghans to leave the country
by the 31st of December the United
Nations has expressed concern about the
expulsion of Afghan Nationals from
Pakistan including what it says are
abuse arbitrary arrest and
detention destruction of property and
personal belongings and
extortion however Pakistan's government
says it has no other option our policy
with regards to uh illegal foreigners
will be applied across the board
irrespective of the nationality and this
uh includes Afghan Afghanistan Nationals
but not just ofans it it will be applied
across the board and individuals
irrespective of their origin and
nationality the interim Afghan
government says the move is unacceptable
and inhumane Afghanistan is in the grip
of another harsh winter and a
organizations's warn of a looming
humanitarian disaster Kamal Hayer Al
jazer
Islamabad make sure to Subs subscribe to
our channel to get the latest news from
Al
jazer